Sydney's first appearance thank you on
her last day on set is it your last day
it is what she killed that bear we were
gonna use today so we had to let her go
under my nails yeah yeah yeah thanks
enjoy your coffee guys thank you for the
coffee said it was like wild
um
well she was like I have this idea and
she was like I got this like rare bear
from the middle of Nevada I thought it'd
be a fun joke we're like that's amazing
yeah that's just revolver
no she took it she choked it she choked
it with her bare hands yeah bare hands
bare hands yeah and when we say choked
it no no no oh dude but she held it
against the ground
go to sleep go to sleep I tried to talk